[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام
هل الفنانون العرب في محل فاعل ام في محل
مجرور لماذا يغطون في سبات عميق في وقت
تتخبط فيه الامه في بحر من الازمات
والتهديدات
اليس حريا بهم ان يتصدروا الواجهه كما
فعلت احدى الفنانات اللبنانيات التي تجوب
البلدان لجمع التبرعات لضحايا العدوان
الاسرائيلي على
لبنان لماذا يكتفي الفنانون العرب بمهمه
سفراء النوايا الحسنه التي تكلفهم بها
الامم المتحده وهي مهمه استعراضيه لا اكثر
ولا اقل اين المسرح السياسي اين الفرق
الغنائيه التي تعبئ الشارع اين الاعمال
الدراميه التي تشحذ
الهمم لماذا اكتفى الكثير من الفنانين بان
يكونوا مجرد مداحين او مسيحي احذيه لهذا
النظام او ذاك اليس حريا بهم ان يرفضوا كل
انواع التدجين
والترويض وان يسخروا الفن للشعوب لا
للسياسيين والحكام وتجار الفن الذين لا هم
لهم سوى تزييف الوعي وتعه
الثقافه لكن في المقابل الا يجب ان يبقى
الفن بعيدا عن السياسه في العالم العربي
لماذا يريد البعض ان يزج بالفنانين في
مضمار ليس مضماره لماذا يريدون اعادتهم
الى زمن زدان اوف والفن البلشفي المؤدلج
البائد ثم لماذا اتهام الفنانين العرب
بانهم ادوات في ايدي هذا النظام او ذاك
الم يتصدى بعضهم لاكثر القضايا الوطنيه
حساسيه في اعماله الفنيه بجراه عز
نظيرها ما العيب في ان يكون الفنان جزءا
من النظام ال طني لماذا يريد البعض من
الفنانين ان ينسلخ عن اوطانهم وحكوماتهم
هل هوليوود مستقله عن النظام الحاكم في
واشنطن ام انها ذراع مفضوح للسياسه
الامريكيه اسئله اطرحها على الهواء مباشره
هنا في الاستوديو على السيد صباح عبيد
نقيب الفنانين في سوريا وعبر الاقمار
الصناعيه من القاهره على الكاتب المسرحي
علي سالم نبدا نقاش بعد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الفاصل اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام
نحن معكم على الهواء مباشره في برنامج
الاتجاه المعاكس بامكانكم التصويت على
موضوع هذه الحلقه هل يمكن فصل الفن عن
السياسه
27.1 نعم
72.9 لا سيد صباح
عبيد اين الفنانون العرب الان انت تعلم ان
الامه من المحيط الى الخليج تمر في بحر من
الازمات والتهديدات الداخليه والخارجيه
ونحن نعلم ان الفن كان دائما مراه الحياه
المعبر عن تطلعات الناس وكل ذلك اين انتم
لماذا لا نسمع لكم صوتا يعني لماذا هذا
الموات اذا صح التعبير قد يكون الاعلام
مقصر في ذلك الفنان العربي في صلب الاحداث
وقد التقينا مع مع الكثير في دارف ومع
المقاومه اللبنانيه وفي العراق وفي وفي كل
الاماكن الساخنه الفن يا سيدي هو سياسه
الان سابدا من حيث انتهيت دكتور هل هوليود
ذراع لامريكا نعم لقد ارعبت العالم
بالافلام عن الحرب العالميه الثانيه منذ
ال 45 وحتى هذه اللحظه طيب بس قبل ان اتي
الى هوليوود والذراع اريد ان تجيب على هذا
السؤال بالتحديد يعني موضوع ان اين انتم
يعني ماذا قلت يعني قلت ان ذهبت الى
دارفور ما لم نسمع عن ذلك اين انتم فعلا
يعني لم لا نسمع لكم لا هنا ولا في اي
مكان اخر كيف تبرر ذلك لم نسمع نحن لا
نمتلك وسائل الاعلام كي تسمع عنا يا سيدي
لقد ذهبنا وجمعنا تبرعات في عده اماكن
عربيه ساخنه ومن المحيط الى الخليج
الفنانين العرب كلهم في بوتقه واحده هي
اتحاد الفنانين العرب وللعز الاتحاد في
بعض اللحظات الان قمنا باتحاد النقابات
المهنيه انا وجمهوريه مصر العربيه وسوريا
والمملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه والجمهوريه
اللبنانيه وعاده الصياغه ولكي نكون فاعلين
وفي صلب الاحداث لانه الفن بال اولا
واخيرا يعنى بالانسان والانسان سياسه بحد
ذاته اها يعني انتم جزء لا يتجزا من
العمليه السياسيه في العالم العربي وانتم
فخورون في ذلك بذلك نعم يا سيدي فخورون
بذلك ن طيب توجهت بهذا الكلام الى السيد
علي سالم في القاهره سيد علي سالم سمعت
هذا الكلام ما العيب في ان يكون الفنان
العربي جزءا لا يتجزا من قضا امته من
العمل الوطني العام من حتى الانظمه اذا صح
التعبير يعني مش هيبقى فنان هيبقى موظف
حكومي مكلف بكتابه قصيده او مكلف بعمل
مسرحيه لازم تكون طالعه طبقا لمواصفات
بتاعه الحكومه مش هيبقى
فنان
هو العمل السياسي ده له رجال السياسه اما
حكايه النقابات فنبه بطبيعتها اصلا
وابتداء وانتهاء شغلتها المهنه الحرفه
شغله النقابه الاهتمام والارتقاء
بالحرف وهي ايضا وهذا مهم للغايه مهمتها
حمايه عضو النقابه من المستهلك وايضا
حمايه المستهلك من عضو النقابه مش عاوزين
نحط ابو قرش على ابو قرشين الذهاب لدارفور
الذهاب للعراق الذهاب لاي مكان تاني ما
يقدرش ندرجه تحت باب الفن والابداع دي
يعني
مهمات بتقوم بها حكومات او ناس حسر
النوايا عشان يشعروا الاخرين انهم معاهم
لكن لما نتكلم على الفن فن حاجه ثانيه فن
مالوش دعوه
بالسياسه الفن له دعوه بالوجود اللي
حواليه بهموم النا ناس بتطلعات باحلامها
ومهتم اكتر ان هو يدفع العزوبه في قلوب
البشر يجعلهم اكثر حبا للحياه باختصار
الفن تحريض على حب الحياه والحكومات بتعمل
حاجه تانيه ومن هنا ياتي الطلاق بين
الابداع الفني والحكومات
سيد عبيد طبعا انا ما ربطت الابداع
بالحكومات العربيه اولا مع احترام الاستاذ
علي سالم لكن لما بدي اناقش هموم الناس
كما هو تكلم هموم الناس سياسه اليس
الانسان العربي مستلب اليس الانسان العربي
مغيب عن واقعه الثقافي والاقتصادي والحياه
وكل شيء اليست مهمه الفن اعاده الصياغه
اليست هناك نظريات تقول الفن ليس الحياه
بل كما يجب ان تكون الحياه الم تكن هموم
المسرحيه والنصوص المسرحيه بالتاريخ عبر
التاريخ كلها سياسه بسياس سياسه الم يكن
جون شتاينبك سياسيا الم يكن شيكسبير
سياسيا الم يكن جوجول سياسيا الم يكن
تشيخوف سياسيا جان جينيه ارابال كورتل الا
يعني بشؤون السياسه
اليس من مهام الفن اولا واخيرا شرح قوانين
الصراع وقوانين الاستلاب التي تحيق بهذا
المواطن العربي المستلب وكشف الخبايا
اليست تحليل الفساد سياسه اليس شرح
المسلسلات السوريه والعربيه عن واقع
الفاسدين والفساد في هذا الوطن العربي
الكبير سياسه اليست هموم الناس التي تكلم
عنها الاستاذ سياسه بحد ذاتها اذا ما ما
هي السياسه هل السياسه اختصاص او مهنه
مثلا السياسه شرف واخلاق وانتماء انساني
اليس الفنان انسانا هل فضاء الفنان فقط هو
الاستديو وال بلاتو والاستديو الاذاعي
فضاء الفنان الحياه كامله في الشارع في
منزله في المقهى في الحياه في كل الزوايا
على الفنان مهمه والفنان طليعي في هذا
المجتمع وانا لم اقل عن الحكومات العربيه
اي شيء وغير مرتبطين بالحكومات العربيه
نحن مرتبطين بالانسان حصرا سناتي على
موضوع الارتباط بالحكومات العربيه طبعا
بعد قليل سيد علي سالم سمعت هذا الكلام
يعني لماذا تريدون من الفنانين العرب ان
ينسلخ عن هموم امتهم وقضايا والقضايا
الكثيره التي يعني تحيق
الان الشعب العربي من المحيط الى الخليج
يعني من جهه تقول يجب على ال الفنان لا
يكون فنانا اذا اقترب من السياسه وانت
تعلم ان الفن في لب السياسه يعني لماذا
حلال على المسرحي التشيكي الشهير فاتسلاف
هافل ان يصبح رئيسا للجمهوريه من كاتب
مسرحي الى الى الى رئيس جمهوريه وكذلك
الامر في الولايات المتحده اما لانه من
جماعتكم يعني بتاع
امريكا
افيل كتب مسرح
ومواطن مواطن مشتغل
بالسياسه والمسرح في
الستينات في بدايه الستينات وخاصه اثناء
الحرب البارده كان مهتم بكل الاشياء دي
اتحاد السوفيتي
وقع جزء من وقوعه نتيجه انعدام
الفن بالتحديد يعني لا شيء يسعد المواطن
احنا ما قلناش الفصل الكامل بين السياسه
ماذا تعتبر السياسه طبعا لازم ننفي بسرعه
حكايه ان شيكسبير راجل سياسه تشيكوف راجل
سياسه ربان ده غير
حقيقي وما يبقي همله على قيد الحياه
الحرفه الصنعه المسرحيه العظيمه التي تتيح
اكبر قدر واكبر مساحه من نبله تمثيل
للممثل كل
الاعمال اللي كانت بتتكلم كان خطا فني انك
ان بطلك يبقى اللي عامل عامل ومطرقه وشكوش
وحاجات من دي وحتى قريب جدا المسلسلات
المصريه الولايه صاحبه القهوه شجاعه
وعظيمه تحارب الانجليز البنت الفقيره
شريفه جدا بس البنت الغنيه سهله وضعيفه
جدا دي تايبس
انماط المؤلفين بيحطوها في الدرج ويطلعو
يشتغلوا بيه واقع الامر مطلوب من الفنان
ان يكون صادق اذا صادق في العمل السياسي
يروح يشتغل في
الحزب يروح يشتغل في الحزب يقنع الجماهير
بافكار الحزب لكن ما يحطها في مسرحيه ما
يقولش يا حزب يا يا حلاوتك يا حزب يا
حبيبي ماقدرش انام لما اسمع صوتك لا
القصيده قصيده وا واذا احنا اعترفنا ان
النقابه شغلتها الحرفه يبقى النقابه
مالهاش دعوه باي افكار سياسيه من اي نوع
في اي مجتمع شغلتها الحرفه سقوط الحرفه في
المنطقه نتيجه لانعدام اهتمام النقابات او
انعدام وعيها بدورها الاساسي فكانت
النتيجه طلعت ناس ليست معتزه بحرفته
عدم الاعتزاز
بالحرف لان الحرفه تصنع الكبرياء عدم
الاعتزاز بالحرف جعل الناس تبحث عن عن
اعتزاز اخر جعلهم يبحثون عما يعتزون به
مجموعه صغيره جدا عندها الحزب بتاعها لكن
الباقي الواسع العريض بيدور على السماء
والجنه شايف من النار وعاوز الجنه وبيدور
على اقرب طريقه الحرفه سقوط الحرفه في
المنطقه العربيه ودعني اتكلم عن نقابات في
مصر ودمشق والاردن وتونس والجزائر وال سيد
علي سالم سيد علي سالتي على موضوع
النقابات سناتي على موضوع النقابات ودوره
نقابات النقابات الفنيه بعد قليل لكن
لنجلي هذه الفكره تحديدا سيد صباح عبيت
يعني لماذا تريدون العوده بنا الى الى
العصر البلشفي الى الفن الملتزم الى عصر
زاد نوف البائد وتريدون ان تجيش الفن والى
ما هنالك يعني الا يكفينا تجار كل هذه
التجارب كل هذه التجارب اثبتت فشلها كما
قال لك السيد علي سالم والدليل على ذلك
يعني انهيار حتى البنيه التحتيه لها يا
صديقي الطيب نحن سنبدا من الاستاذ علي
سالم يقول النقابات نحن لم نذكر النقابات
نح الفنانين سي على موضوع النقابات بس كي
لا ندخل هل الفن حرفه جافه الفن ادوات
تعبير وارقى اشكال التعبير الانساني
الفنان التشكيلي يرسم لوحه ليعبر الشاعر
يقول قصيده ليعبر الممثل يقول دور ليعبر
هذه ادوات تعبير راقيه الم يكن بابلو
نيرودا سياسيا وهو يتكلم عن الشعر الم يكن
متنبي سياسيا الم يكن يحرض جيوش سيف
الدوله على القتال مثلا الفنان منفصل عن
قضايا الانسان فنان بصلب القضايا ويجب ان
يكون طليعه القضايا انا لا اتكلم لا عن
نقابات ولا عن احزاب ولا عن حكومات انا
اتكلم عن الفنان كفنان وعن الفنانه كفنه
الفنان العربي فنان طليعي وضاقت به منطقه
الشرق الاوسط ايضا واصبح يطلب الى هوليود
الان طيب اي اي اي فنان طليعي اي فنان
طليعي انت تتحدث عن اشياء ربما لا تكون
موجوده اي فنان طليعي الفنانون العرب
مغلوب على امرهم ليسوا في محل فاعل باي
حال من الاحوال يعني ما تتحدث لي مثلا عن
الذين يكلفوا او يعني الذين يكلفون بمهام
سفراء النوايا الحسنه بتاع الامم المتحده
ماذا بالضبط هذه ليست سياسه يا سيدي انا
لا اتكلم عن النوايا الحسنه انا اتكلم عن
الشرف والاخلاق والانتماء للانسان هل
الشرف والاخلاق امور بائده مثلا هل
الانتماء للانسان والدفاع عن حقوقه
المستلفه هل الشرف اصبح مساله بائده وبلش
فيه وما هي البلشفيه الشيوعيه يقصد العص
الشيوعي مثلا نحن ليس لنا علاقه بكل هذا
الكلام نحن نعيش في منطقه قوانين الصراع
بها غلبت الحكومات وغلبت الانظمه العربيه
والانظمه العربيه لا تعي قوانين الصراع
اذا مهمه المثقف
والطليعية فنانه طبعا اقصد الفنان العربي
فنان وفنانه انا بهذا الكلام نعم طيب طيب
سيد علي سالم يعني انت تتحدث كما لو انك
يعني لم تطلع باي حال من الاحوال وانت
كاتب مسرحي
معروف على الحركات المسرحيه في الغرب
تحديدا يعني الغرب سبقنا ب باشواط كثيره
في ميدان الديمقراطيه وعلاقه الفن
بالسياسه والى ما هنالك من هذا الكلام
يعني هل تستطيع لماذا تناسيت مثلا ان فتره
الستينات والسبعينات في الغرب وفي
بريطانيا تحديدا شهدت نهوض المسرح السياسي
الذي سيطر لاكثر من عقدين من الزمان لعلك
سمعت بجون اردن الكاتب الكبير ادوارد بوند
الكاتب الكبير هاوارد بيكر هاوارد برنتون
كل هؤلاء الذين تصدوا لمرحله مرحله حساسه
جدا في تاريخ بلادهم بالمسرح السياسي كل
تلك الفتره كانت م مسرحه
سياسيا استاذ في صل انا اتكلم عن هنا في
المنطقه بتاعتنا وفي اللحظه دي من الزمن
وكل ده عشناه واحنا صغيرين احنا عشنا
القاد الايديولوجي وعشنا النقاد الجمالين
وعشنا المعارك دي كلها وعشنا لما الكاتب
تبقى موهبته ضعيفه ويحول الشغل الى شعارات
احنا عشنا ده
كله انا احنا انا مش مختلف مع صديقي الشرف
الانساني يجعل فنان يستمع لصوت ضميره فقط
ويستمع لصوت قلبه فقط ويعمل شغله لكن
استخدام كلمه من نوع طليعي واستخدام كلمه
الصراع والدخول في الصراع احنا ما احنا
خرجنا من المدرسه دي انا احد خريجي هذه
المدرسه بس حتى الان لازم نقول ونفهم
الناس الفن هو الفن الفن يعني ما يعني ولا
يعني غير ما يعني وهنا حريه الفنان ان انا
اخوفه او اغريه بحكايه السياسه وهو مواطن
في النهايه فرد وفنان فرد ضعيف بما هو
انسان بشكل عام الفنان المبدع كالانا
الخزفي غالي جدا وسهل الكسر لما يقعد في
مجتمع ويلاقي ان السلطه
بتاعته بتغريه او
بتخوف هيعمل تنازلات في فنه هو اضعف من
انه يقاوم حكومات سلطويه وعشان كده انا
مصر على المستوى النظري لا احد من حقه
يقول الفنان يعمل ايه فتره الستينات في
مصر قامت على اكتاف هؤلاء الذين تربوا في
تعاليم الليبراليه في الاربعينات لما قامت
الثوره مليئين بالاحلام فلمع ونجحوا انما
الجيل الحالي من الفنانين هو جيل
الستينات الجيل الحالي في المسرح والسينما
هو جيل الستينات اما جيل الستينات فده جيل
الليبراليه المصريه هو اللي عمل المصرح
المصري وكنا مؤمنين باللي بنعمله وما كناش
بنرى ابدا اي تناقض بين سياسه الدوله وبين
الفن لكن مره واحده لو حصل اي تناقض بين
الدوله وبين فنان مبدع وجرب ان عمل حاجه
هي شايفاها ضدها هيروح في داهيه عشان كده
من الاول كده يا نحله لا تلغيني ولا انا
عاوز عسلك ال فنان المبدع مش عاوز عسل
الدوله وعلى الدوله في الوقت المناسب في
الوقت نفسه ان تهتم
به لان هو ده ملح الارض هو ده ده اللي
بيسعد الناس بكلمه في قصيده بحرف في نوته
موسيقيه باغنيه بعرض
مبهج
البهجه اساس المساله البهجه هي مطلبنا
ومطلب الناس انما هنتكلم عن دور السياسه
وفينه وفنان مناضل وطليع المثقفين وما
يجبش نحط الفنان جام المثقف بواجه عام
مثقف صفه فنان دي حاجه ولكن المثقف بشكل
عام هو المحمل بهموم وطنه في كل المهن هو
الشريحه العليا في كل مهنه طيب لكن الفنان
المبدع ده مساله اخرى يتطلب حريه ويتطلب
مساعدته وحمايته من اي طيارات خارجيه قد
تؤثر على ضميره
الابداعي طيب جميل جدا وصلت الفكره سيد
صباح بيد وكانه يقول ام نعم انه انتم خاصه
وانك انت مثلا ليس فقط نقيبا للفنانين بل
ايضا عضوا في مجلس الشعب يقول لك يعني
يقول لك وانا مستقل ايضا طيب يقول لك
سناتي على موضوع الاستقلال بعد قليل لكن
يقول لك بعباره اخرى انه هناك فرق بين
الفن والابداع الحقيقي وبين اولئك الذين
يخلطون زيد بعبيد كما تفعل انت وامثالك
طبعا يا سيدي انا سابدا من حيث انتهى
الاستاذ علي سالم الاستاذ علي سالم اقول
فن للبهجه الانسان المبتهج الا يكون مستقر
اقتصاديا مثلا اها الا يكون مستقر عاطفيا
الا يكون مستقر سياسيا حتى يبتهج هل يبتهج
الجائع هل يبتهج المظلوم هل يبتهج المقهور
هل يبتهج اصحاب الشوارع الخلفيه كل الفنون
العربيه طبعا انا لا اقصد كل ال زوايا
معينه بس الغالبيه من الفنون تحكي عن
الشوارع الاماميه انما الشوارع الخلفيه
المضطهده والمغيب والتي تقطع عنها
الكهرباء والتي تظلم ليلا نهارا اليست من
مهمه الفنان الدفاع عنها انا مصر على
مقوله الفن ليس الحياه بل كما يجب ان تكون
الحياه انا لا اتكلم لا عن شعارات اتكلم
عن فعل على الارض عن فعل حقيقي على الارض
واجب الفنان جمع التبرعات والنضال وتحريض
الناس المستلب وهناك الكثير من هذه
الامثله في في البلدان العربيه الكثير من
الفنانين تصدوا للكثير من القضايا الحساسه
بجراه بالغه يعني تريد ان تقول طبعا طبعا
حتى الفن السوري وبعض المسلسلات السوريه
وصلت حد التحليل مثال امس قلته في اجتماع
عام انه الفاسد والفاسده كمثال بعوض طين
فوق مستنقع الفن العربي غالبا كان يتكلم
عن البعو ويتجاهل هذا المستنقع الذي يفرز
هذا الفساد انا اتكلم الان عن تحليل الوضع
وتجفيف هذا المستنقع ويجب التصدي لعصر
الانحطاط الذي غيبت فيه الفنون المحليه
واصبح الجميع يغنون بلهجه واحده وكانها
عولمه من النوع الرديء انا لست ضد العولمه
الجيده انا ضد العولمه الرديئه نحن عندنا
مهام واستحقاقات هائله للتصدي لها بس بس
يا سيد عبيد انت تتحدث كما لو يعني كما لو
ان الفنانين العرب يعني كما لو انهم
ثوريون من الطراز الاول وياخذون معارك انت
تعلم ان هذا الفنان حتى على مستوى التصدي
للقضايا الوطنيه والعامه والى ما هنالك
مغلوب على امره انت تتحدث عن معالجه
الفساد من يعني في الكثير من الاحيان يلجا
الفنان العربي الى التاريخ ليتحدث عن
الكثير من القضايا الراهنه يلجا الى مساله
ال هستور سيز اذا صح التعبير ويسقطها على
الواقع والى ما هنالك اين هؤلاء الفنانون
الذين يتصدون انتم مغلوبون على امركم انتم
عباره عن عتله عن ادوات في يد السلطه من
المحيط الى الخليج من ممتلكات الدوله
العربيه لا اكثر ولا اقل نحن لسنا ادوات
في يد السلطه يا دكتور نهائيا مع الاحترام
للاستاذ علي
س عضو في مجلس شعب انت انت لماذا تدخل ع
مجلس الشعب انا مرشح مستقل ومدعوم من كل
الناس الشرفاء في هذا الوطن في محافظه
مدينه دمشق حصرا واخذت الثاني على مدينه
دمشق انا لست هنا بصدد هذا الكلام لكن انا
مرشح مستقل لا انتمي الى اي حزب انا انتمي
الى الانسان في وطني انتمي الى محيطي
الجغرافي الى سوريا والى الوطن العربي
انتمي الى قضايا الانسان الان انا ما
يدهشني في هذه الحياه وفي هذه اللحظه طبعا
ليس ردا على استاذ علي سالم ولا على غيره
انه الانسان الذي يحمل قضايا وهموم الناس
اصبح انسانا يشكي امره انا لا اتكلم عن
الثوريه بمفهومها التقليدي ومفهوم
الستينات والاربعينات والخمسينات وببدا
السبعينات انا اتكلم عن عام 2007 وما يحيط
بهذه المنطقه من ظلم واجحاف واضطهاد
واحتلال وتهديدات و مساله القطب ال واحد
ومساله القطب ونص ومساله هؤلاء اليس واجب
الانسان العربي يا اخي عم نتكلم عن
الانسان عموما اين اخلاق المواطن الحقيقي
اليس الفنان هو من الطليعه الطليعه ليس
بمفهومها الايديولوجي يا اخي بمفهومها
الانساني ان تكون في طليعه البشر يوجد بعض
الحكومات العربيه تمشي قبل شعوبها ولكن
80% او 90% من الحكومات العربيه تمشي خلف
شعوبها انا مستعد اي حكومه تمشي امام
شعوبها ان اسير مع بس لم تجب على هذا
السؤال باختصار يعني يعني تريد ان تقول
للمشاهد بان الفنان العربي فنان طليعي
ومستقل ومتحرر ويستطيع ان ان يعيد انتاج
الحياه كما قلت قبل قليل ونحن نعلم ان
الفنان كالمثل ككل النقابات في العالم
العربي مصادره يمتلكها الحزب الحاكم في اي
مكان من من من من هذا العالم العربي
البائس يعني هل تستطيع ان تنكر ذلك تتحدث
لي عن استقلاليه وطلعيه و و بعرف شو وانتم
جزء لا يتجزا من انتم عتلات ادوات نعم انا
استطيع ان انكر ذلك في بلدي نقابه
الفنانين في سوريا مستقله ماديا ومعنويا
وبكل شيء وهي صاحبه القرار في كل شيء وهي
المشرف الوحيد على الفن حسب القانون رقم
13 لكن هذا مساله
ليس نحن بصدد مساله انا لا اتكلم بشكل عام
انه كل الفنانين العرب لابسين مثل بعض
الدول لبس واحد وماشيين بمسيره واحده مثل
اذا انا اتكلم عندما يكون ان صوتا واحدا
حرا اكثريه حلو انا لا اتكلم هذا شعاري في
الانتخابات ايضا عندما انت تتكلم لا اتكلم
انا عن العموم انا لا لست مخولا لاتكلم عن
كل الفنانين العرب اصلا يعني انا مخول
اتكلم عن محيط الجغرافي وعن بعض النقابات
التي اتحدت معها وعندنا منهاج عمل وخطه
عمل وعندنا استحقاقات ايضا كثيره للمستقبل
وكلها تعنى بشؤون الناس والاوطان والاخلاق
والشرف والشرف ليس بمفهومه الكلاسيكي انا
عندما اتكلم لا اتكلم بالحدود الضيقه
للكلمه حلو جميل جدا سيد علي سالم سمعت
هذا الكلام يعني ما العيب ما العيب في في
في هذه النقابات هناك الان نقابات
للفنانين في العالم العربي تدخل في معترك
السياسه ما العيب في ان تكون هذه النقابات
وهؤلاء الفنانون حتى جزءا من النظام من
الحكومات من الاوطان لماذا تريدون لهؤلاء
ان ينسلخ عن اوطانهم عن قضاياهم عن كل عن
كل هذا الكلام ما العيب ما
العيب لم نطلب من احد الانسلاخ عن
اوطانه
ولكن في سوريا ومصر في القرون الوسطى على
الاقل من 800 سنه كانت هناك نقابات كان في
شيخ
النحاسين شيخ النجارين شيخ البنائين شيخ
السقايين تعنى بالمهنه هذه نقابه للمهنه
وظيفتها حمايه المهنه وحمايه عضو النقابه
من المستهلك وحمايه المستهلك من عضو
النقابه اي انحراف عن الخط ده هيعمل لك
نقابات يا سياسيه يا متطرفه
دينيه اللي احنا بنعاني منه دلوقتي ايه
سقوط الحرفه مره اخرى الحرفه تشعر الناس
بالكبرياء
والكبرياء يمنع الناس من التطرف انا تربيت
في دمياط وهي مدينه فرعونيه
صناعيه بس بس بس سيد علي سالم كيف سقطت
الحرفه سيد علي سالم بس دقيقه بس كيف بس
كيف سقطت الحرفه كيف سقطت الحرفه لناخذ
لناخذ النقابات لناخذ هذه دقيقه دقيقه
لناخذ النقابه التي يمثلها السيد صباح بيد
هنا كيف سقطت الحرفه كل هذه الاعمال
الفنيه التي ارتقت الى مستوى عالمي سقطت
كيف سقطت هي يعني بالعكس الحرفه في اوجهها
كما يقول صباح عبيد الان بالرغم بغض النظر
عن ارتباطها السياسي او دخولها المعترك
السياسي او الى ما هنالك من هذا الكلام
الحرفه الفنيه في
اوجهها والله لستو في مقام تقيييم اعمال
ما وصلتني انا اشتغلت مع فنانين السوريين
وعرض لي مسرحيات كتير في دمشق وحلب وفي
الجيش
السوري اصدقائي الفنانين من جيلي نعتز
بصدقهم
وبحرفية
الارتقاء قياده الشعب المصري
لا اه
ما اولا اولا هذا السيد يتكلم بانه هي
الحرفه وتطوير الحرفه هذا كلام مضبوط
ساقول له همسا لهذا الكاتب المشهور انه
الفن هندسه بشريه واعاده صياغه للانسان
وجد الفن منذ الخليقه لاعاده صياغه بني
الانسان ريبرودكشن اوف لايف بالضبط القصه
انه انا لما بدي انا عم اقدم هذه المساله
للناس وتطوير العمل النقابي تطوير اليه
العمل النقابي وتطوير المهنه والحر هذه
لعبه جماعيه تاتي بالتقادم لا تاتي بين
عشيه وضحاها نحن بالنقابات العربيه عموما
لا نتكلم لا على انتماء سياسي نقابه الجمه
انا انتمي لاي دوله عربيه حكومتها او
رئيسها يمشي امام الجماهير ساكون معه على
سراء والضراء الانسان عندما السياسي
يتجاوز الجماهير يكون سياسي متفوق مثل
الفنان يكون لانه هو فنان في السياسه الفن
هندسه بشريه شو معناه الهندسه بس يا سيد
صباح هندسه بشريه جميل جدا بس يعني لو
نظرنا الى الواقع نعم ليس فقط سياسيا الفن
هو عباره عن يعني احدى ممتلكات الدوله
العربيه بل ايضا لوجستيا
وتمويلي انتم ماذا بامكانكم ان تفعلوا
الان في وجه الرقابه في وجه المتم وين
العرب الذين ينفقون الملايين ان لم نقل
المليارات على تعير الفن على تعير الثقافه
لا حول ولا قوه لكم لا تستطيعوا انتم
محاصرون من كل حدب وصو انت تتحدث
رومانسيات للوهله الاولى اتحدث رومانسيات
لكن احيانا يوجد احتلالات بقيت 400 سنه
وتحرر تحررت الشعوب منها انا اتكلم عن
مقدمه اولى للحركه ضد عصر الانحطاط هذا
عصر انحطاط بالمطلق كما تكلمت سياده راس
المال الملوث والمحطات الملوثه والمحطات
التي تشبه يعني سنقول كلمه بسيطه عندما
محطه تقدم لي نساء عاريات وعاريات تماما
الا تصبح مثل النخاس الذي يقدم نساء
عاريات لي ما ماذا اسميه ممارس اقدم مهنه
في التاريخ مثلا هذه المحطات هذه المحطات
تمارس اقدم مهنه في التاريخ وانا مصد على
ذلك طيب الفن يا سيدي هو اعاده صياغه
اعاده صياغه والدفاع عن الحقوق المستلب
الدفاع عن الثقافات اليس الكاتب المسرحي
رجل مثقف يكتب لي المسرحيه لاتبنى هذا
النص ويدافع عن وجهه نظره الانسانيه وعن
وجهه نظره في هذه الحياه طيب جميل جدا سيد
علي سالم يعني نفهم من كلامك ب ب من من من
البدايه يعني تتهم بما معناه النقابات
العربيه والفنانين العرب بانهم يعني
يخسرون ابداعهم وفنهم فيما لو دخلوا
السياسه والى ما هنالك واصبحوا جزءا من
اللعبه طيب لماذا لا ننظر الى العالم
المتقدم الذي نتشدق ليل نهار بفضائله
وبتقلي والى ما هنالك من هذا الكلام لناخذ
هوليوود هذه المؤسسه الفنيه العالميه هل
تستطيع ان تنكر يعني لماذا تاخذ على على
الفنانين العرب انهم يجارون الحكام ويجرون
السياسات والانظمه ولا تاخذ على هوليوود
التي تعتبر ذراعا مفضوحا للسياسه
الامريكيه كل السياسات الامريكيه التي
يراد تمريرها تاتي عن طريق هوليوود يعني
حتى حتى في الغرب في البلدان الديمقراطيه
الفن ليس منفصلا عن السياسه بل هو عتله من
عتلات السياسه وكل الكلام عن انه الفن
مستقل وكذا كذب في
كذب يا استاذ فيصل يعني مش
عاوز معلش ما تصدقش حكايه ان هوليود زراع
للحكومه الامريكيه هوليود فيها مبدعين من
العالم كله وده سر تجدد السينما الامريكيه
ما بتسمع عن مخرج عظيم سنرست عظيم بتغريه
باي طريقه عشان
يشتغل هوليود مش هتشتغل عند الحكومه
الامريكيه لانها
هتخسر هتخسر هتخسر فبلاش نفاهم المشاهد في
الوطن العربي ان ان الناس كلها زينا لا
الناس مش زينا اسمحلي بسرعه هندسه البشر
الومان
انجين من مفردات المركسيه لا اخطر شيء في
الدنيا اعاده صياغه الانسان او اعاده صنع
الانسان انا شخصيا كتبتها في مسرحيه من
مسرحياتي وانا
حزين
ونادم لان كنت بفكر بالشكل ده الانسان مش
محتاج اعاده صياغه الانسان تم صياغته
كبشر كفنانين محتاجين
نحرض اكتر على حب الحياه وفهمها
والاستمتاع بيها في ناس تانيه شغلتها
تعلمه تمشيه في تمشيه زي ما تمشيه انا
شغلتي كفنان ان انا اقول له الحياه جميله
جدا من فضلك دافع
عنها بس مش اكتر من كده من خلال الحرفه من
خلال بلوتينج من خلال الحبكه انا بتكلم
كمسرح جي فيعني وحكايه ان انا همشي ورا
رئيس اي دوله الجماهير بتمشي وراه لا لا
مش همشي وراه انا وهو كمان ما يجيبش يمشي
قدام الجماهير شغلته يقعد في البيت
والجماهير علي سالم بس سيد علي سالم نعود
الى نعود الى الفن في الغرب يعني انت تصور
الفن في الغرب يعني بطريقه ايضا لا نريد
ان ان نضلل اذا صح التعبير الشارع العربي
لا في امريكا وفي الغرب الفن ايضا عتله
انت تعلم كيف استغلت هوليوود لرد من
الزمان ضد الشيوعيه وانت تعرف كيف تستخدم
الان كتله ضد الاسلام وضد العرب وهناك
يعني اذا اردنا ان ان نعدد الافلام
الامريكيه الموجهه لاغراض سياسيه وللترويج
للسياسات الامريكيه في الخارج لا تعد ولا
تحصى حتى الفنانون الامريكيون والاوروبي
الذين يخرجون عن السرب يتم تهميشهم وتتم
ملاحقتهم وانت تعرف ماذا يحدث لهم يعني هل
تريد ان انظر ماذا يحدث لمايكل مور صاحب
فيلم فهرن هايت لانه فضح السياسه
الامريكيه اصبح مهمشا اصبح مضطهدا اصبح
ملاحقا الى متى نكذب على الجماهير ايضا
منذ البدايه بس
دقيقه يا استاذ
فيصل الفن متوسط القيمه موجود في كل مكان
السينارست او المخرج في السينما الامريكيه
في عنده بضاعه جاهزه دلوقتي اسمها التطرف
الاسلامي هيشتغل في الحاجات دي بشفت انا
عدد كبير قوي من الافلام رديئه متوسطه
القيمه انا احدثك عن الفن عالي القيم الذي
سيستمر هيعيش اذا احنا اتهمنا هوليود ان
ما عندهاش هذا النوع لا
بنتنى بنبقى بن
تجنى مش على طول كده الغرب رديء في كل
حاجه هو رضي في حاجات اه بس مش في كل حاجه
خطر خطر علينا ويفقد هنا النظره النقديه ف
اللي انا عاوز اقوله احنا مش مختلفين في
حاجه
خالص
ولكن الحكومات عليها ان
تبتعد
النقابات ليست احد ادارات الحكومه ليست
احد ادارات الدوله وعليها ان تبتعد حرصا
على مجتمعاتها وعلى المثقفين في المنطقه
العربيه ان ينظروا الى هذه المساله بجد
شديد اذا خسرنا الحرفه هنروح في 60 داهيه
الانسان مش هيبقى له حاجه يعتز بيه الى
الاوهام فارجوكم فكروا في اللي انا بقوله
على النقابات مره اخرى ان تعود لما كانت
عليه من 600 سنه لحمايه المهنه لحمايه عضو
المهنه من مستهلك لحمايه المستهلك من عضو
النقابه مهم جدا السنوات القادمه احد احد
الطرق لمكافحه
التطرف وصلت الفكره كيف ترد على هذا
الكلام قبل قليل يعني قبل قبل ان نمر على
هذه اريدك ان تجيب على هذه النقطه
بالتحديد لكن لكن يعني يعني اليس من العيب
في واقع الامر ان نشبه واقع الفن في
العالم العربي بواقع الفن في امريكا
وبوليوود وبكذا يعني بشقط قلم بجره قلم
نقول انه هوليوود هي عباره عن ذراع
للسياسه الامريكيه او ان الفن في الغرب
ايضا مسيس والى ما هنالك من من هذا الكلام
بطريقه فجه يعني يقول لك يجب ان لا نضلل
الشارع العربي بمثل هذه الاقاويل باختصار
الوقت يداهمنا نحن لا نضلل الشارع العربي
يا سيدي ولكن الاستاذ علي سالم يسمح ل
للفن الامريكي ان يتناول القضيه الاسلاميه
لانها بين يديه ونحن بين يدينا الاف
الاحلال الامريكي وغيره ممنوع ان نتصدى له
مثلا ليذكره ب ليا كازان المحكمه
المكارثيه منعته من الحصول على الاوسكار
لانه واحد مخبر سخيف اتهمه انه هو الشيوعي
حرمو من الهيئه هل فيلم اطول يوم في
التاريخ الذي مثله هنري فوندا وارعب الناس
به العوده من الجحيم ومعركه بيرل هاربر
مئات الافلام عنها الم تكن سياسه هذه
السينما الامريكيه ممنهجه عبر عبر التاريخ
منذ الازل حتى الان في تطور مستمر لارعاب
العالم من الجندي الامريكي ومن سي اي اي
والسي اي اي تمتلك عده شركات في هوليود
وهذا معروف للعالم اجمع تمتلك لتسويق
افكارها يعني ليس ليس فقط ال الفن العربي
هو المرتبط بالاجهزه و والى ما هنالك ايضا
في امريكا ايضا مرتبطين بالاجهزه بكل
الدنيا بكل الدنيا حتى فرانك سيناترا
تبنته المافيا الامريكيه كي
نجح لا يوجد كلام بهذا مقنن واضح وهذا
منتمي وهذا غير منتمي وهذا تابع للدوله
يوجد هناك انسان شريف ويوجد انسان ضعيف
الانسان الضعيف يا دكتور يتمثل الاقوى منه
دائما يتمثله كيف بالتقليد فيصبح نسخه
تايوانيه صغيره امام نسخه حقيقيه مثلا
عندما تقترب امريكا خطوه من المنطقه يخرج
لنا 20 معارض دفعه واحده وكل معارض لا
يتخيل الا الدولار ويتخيل النعماء المثقف
عندما يفسد هو اشد فتكا واشد خطوره من اي
من السياسي ومن الانسان العادي ومن السواد
اعظم بس بس يا سيدي انت تتحدث عن المثقف
عندما ي يفسد يعني السواد الاعظم وخاصه من
الفنانين هم يعني اذا لم يكونوا فاسدين
مفسدون اذا صح التعبير يعني كيف نتحدث عن
ذلك كلمه اخيره ردا على كلام السيد علي
سالم بخصوص النقابات النقابات الفنانين
نقابات الفنانين يجب ان تبتعد يجب ان
تستقل يجب ان ان لا تكون لا تكون مطيه
لاحد والنقابات العربيه الفن مازالت مطيه
مازالوا عباره الفنان كشاعر البلاط مداح
او قداح باختصار كلمه واحده باختصار نقابه
مصر عن عندما اتحدت معنا ولبنان والاردن
لا ليست تابعه للدوله اشكرك جزيل الشكر
انتهى الوقت مشاهدي الكرام لم يبقى لنا
الا ان اشكر ضيفين هنا في الاستديو السيد
صباح عبيد نقيب الفنانين السوريين وعضو
مجلس الشعب السوري وعبر الاقمار الصناعيه
من القاهره السيد علي سالم الكاتب المسرحي
نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحتى ذلك
الحين وفيصل قاسم يحييكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا